And let's be completely brutally honest, right? When I code, maybe you two, when we code, we get the dopamine hit, right? That at the end of the day is a good reason why we love doing what we do, right? And, you know, whether you do, when you build things, when you see those test passing, when you're in that kind of flow, when you're in that loop, you're getting that positive feedback. that dopamine. And several people I've talked to say that, you know, prompting AI does not, does not scratch that itch, does not do that for them. It just doesn't. The number one thing you can do for your career is go to the meetups, go to the conferences, do the networking. Probably the most
说实话，这绝对是非常直截了当的，对吧？当我写代码时，也许你们两个，当我们写代码时，我们会获得多巴胺的快感，对吧？归根结底，这就是为什么我们热爱我们所做的事情的一个很好的原因，对吧？而且，你知道，无论你做什么，当你构建东西时，当你看到那些测试通过时，当你处于那种心流状态时，当你处于那个循环中时，你就会得到那种积极的反馈。那种多巴胺。我交谈过的几个人说，你知道，向人工智能提示并不能，不能解决那种渴望，对他们来说没有这种效果。根本就没有。你能为你的职业生涯做的第一件事就是去参加聚会，去参加会议，去进行社交。可能最
meaningful thing you can do is maintain your friendships and relationships with the folks that you enjoy meeting up with. Welcome to ADSP the podcast, episode 290, recorded on May 27, 2006. My name is Connor and today with my co-host, Ben, we chat about AI, career advice, life advice, and more. Shima and I, I have to get Shima's the book, but she read this book recently. I'm not, it has to do with the medium is the message. It's not like a book by Claude Shannon, but it's a book about...
有意义的事情就是维持你与那些你喜欢相聚的人的友谊和关系。欢迎来到 ADSP 播客，第 290 期，录制于 2006 年 5 月 27 日。我的名字是康纳（Connor），今天我和我的联合主持人本（Ben）一起聊聊人工智能、职业建议、生活建议等等。希玛（Shima）和我——我得拿希玛的那本书，不过她最近读了这本书。我不是，这跟“媒介即讯息”有关。这倒不是克劳德·香农（Claude Shannon）写的书，而是一本关于……
Wait, Claude Shannon? Is Claude Shannon? Sorry, Marshall McLuhan. Marshall McLuhan. Yeah, Claude Shannon is information theory, sorry. Yeah. But I think, well, I don't know. don't think Clyde Chattano comes up in the book. I think it's Marshall McLuhan.
等等，克劳德·香农？是克劳德·香农吗？抱歉，是马歇尔·麦克卢汉（Marshall McLuhan）。马歇尔·麦克卢汉。是的，克劳德·香农是搞信息论的，抱歉。是的。但我想，嗯，我不知道。我觉得克劳德·香农并没有出现在书里。我觉得那是马歇尔·麦克卢汉。
Anyways, in this book, I'm not going to remember the name of it, but I'll put it in the links. I think I'll ask. I think I know this book. Do you? I can't remember the title either, but I think it's a book I have. I mean, I sometimes can message my wife. What is the name of the Marshall McLuhan book you like? And while she may or may not respond to me because she's a busy person and sometimes I won't hear back from her for a couple hours. Let me look back, yeah. Laws of media? Laws of media.
无论如何，在这本书里，我不记得它的名字了，但我会把它放在链接里。我想我会问。我想我知道这本书。是吗？我也记不清书名了，但我觉得那是我有的书。我的意思是，我有时可以给我的妻子发信息。你喜欢的马歇尔·麦克卢汉的那本书叫什么名字？虽然她可能会也可能不会回复我，因为她是个大忙人，有时我得等上好几个小时才能听到她的回复。让我想想，对吧。媒介的法则？媒介的法则。
That doesn't ring a bell. Marshall and Eric McLuhan. Laws of media, the new science. No, that's not that one. Okay, anyway, that was my guess. Well, I'm asking, let's see if the AI can get it based off of my question. Because the book goes back. It's like asking the AI, where did I lose my car keys?
这听起来不怎么耳熟。马歇尔和埃里克·麦克卢汉（Eric McLuhan）。《媒介的法则：新科学》。不对，不是那一本。好吧，总之，那只是我的猜测。嗯，我问一下，看看人工智能能不能根据我的问题猜出来。因为这本书追溯了过去。这就像问人工智能，我的车钥匙丢哪儿了？
Well, the AI is giving me Marshall McLuhan's work. It wasn't written by him. It was recommended on an Ezra Klein podcast by the guest. Anyways, it goes back over the last couple hundred years and looks at what the primary medium that people communicated by. Right. The AI said, oh, no. See, the AI's first recommendation is the people,
嗯，人工智能给我的确实是马歇尔·麦克卢汉的作品。它不是他写的。是在伊兹拉·克莱恩（Ezra Klein）的播客上由嘉宾推荐的。无论如何，它追溯了过去几百年，并研究了人们用来沟通的主要媒介是什么。对吧。人工智能说，哦，不。你看，人工智能的第一个推荐是人们，
paradox of democracy. That is not it. But then right at the bottom, it mentions amusing ourselves to death by Neil Postman. And that is definitely the name of the book. And I haven't read the book. My wife has, and she really likes it. But it talks about, you know, back in the day when TV wasn't a thing and radio wasn't a thing, you know, people had newspapers and people used to sit at dinner tables and, like, you know, debate politics and talk about what's good for society. And, you know, it used to be a thing where people would kind of like give little monologues at dinners. And, you know, maybe this sounds terrible to the generation of 2026. But I think it's quite interesting. And people used to go, apparently. And this is all third hand from my wife, who's read this book, once again, I haven't read
民主的悖论。那不是。但紧接着在最底部，它提到了尼尔·波兹曼（Neil Postman）的《娱乐至死》（Amusing Ourselves to Death）。这绝对是书名。我还没读过这本书。我妻子读过，她非常喜欢。但它谈到，你知道，在过去电视和广播还不存在的时候，你知道，人们有报纸，人们过去常常坐在餐桌旁，就像，你知道，辩论政治并谈论什么对社会有利。而且，你知道，过去人们在晚宴上发表一点独白也是常有的事。而且，你知道，也许这对2026年的一代人来说听起来很糟糕。但我认为这相当有趣。显然，人们以前经常去。而且这全都是通过我读过这本书的妻子得来的第三手消息，再说一遍，我没有读过
the book. But like, people would go to debates where there was no applause allowed. The debates would be, like, very civil. And they would last for like hours, like four, five, six hours. And they were, it was considered like very important that, you know, these potential leaders of these countries, and I think it mostly focuses on America. They would go and have. these, you know, long-winded from our standards, debates. And anyways, then it goes to the evolution of when radio came out and when TV came out and when the internet came out. And every single time, one of these new technologies came out, like, there was a moral panic
这本书。但是，人们会去参加不允许鼓掌的辩论。辩论会非常文明。而且它们会持续几个小时，比如四个、五个、六小时。并且它们被认为非常重要，你知道，这些国家的潜在领导人，而且我认为它主要集中在美国。他们会去进行那些，按照我们的标准来看很冗长的辩论。无论如何，然后它讲到了广播出现、电视出现以及互联网出现的演变。每一次，当这些新技术之一出现时，都会产生一种道德恐慌
and, like, an outcry of, like, the impact that this was going to have on society. And, like, one of the kind of takeaways of the book is, like, a lot of the outcries, specifically with respect to, like, the internet and TV came true. Like, if you look at the political... of the world, one of the things it said is that, like, with TV, it's going to become a form of entertainment and no longer, like, a debate of what is best for society. And without naming any names, you know, you look around and you go, huh, maybe the people that were outcrying back when these things were happening had a point.
并且，就像是对这将对社会产生的影响发出强烈抗议。而且，这本书的一些收获之一是，许多抗议，特别是关于互联网和电视的抗议，都成真了。如果你看看这个世界的政治……其中一件事是，随着电视的出现，它将成为一种娱乐形式，不再是对什么对社会最好的辩论。而不点名任何人，你知道，你环顾四周就会发现，嗯，也许当年这些事情发生时发出抗议的人是有道理的。
I mean, from a certain point of view, it is true. It is also true to say that, you know, blue st. Jean's, blue state, lam, mchios, right? It's, it's, most of the problems of today are the same problems people had 100 years ago, you know, in terms of society and the way politics works, a lot of things were the same. But it's also true, like we were saying earlier, like, try doing a math test from the 1890s, and you will find out how poor your math education is from the 1990s, right? Yeah. How did we start talking about this? Oh, right, bringing someone on and the different types of, is it even generous to call my vibe coded sites software, you know, but like the different types of code or software out there,
我的意思是，从某种角度来看，这也是真的。同样真实的说法是，你知道，蓝州，拉姆，麦基奥斯，对吧？这是，今天的大多数问题和人们100年前遇到的问题是一样的，你知道，就社会和政治运作方式而言，很多事情都是一样的。但这也是真的，就像我们刚才说的，尝试做一份1890年代的数学测试，你就会发现你从1990年代受到的数学教育有多么糟糕，对吧？是的。我们是怎么开始聊到这个的？哦，对了，邀请某人上节目以及不同类型的——把我的这种“氛围代码”网站称为软件到底算不算慷慨，你知道的——但现有的不同类型的代码或软件，
I think come with a different sets of concerns. Yeah, concerns. How comfortable, you know, with specifically how one is using AI, you know, the types of code that I guess you are primarily using AI for, how does that influence, you know, you're feeling? If most of the code that you're writing is for work and going on millions of devices around the world, obviously that's going to inform. how you feel about these tools. I try not to be, I try not,
我认为伴随着不同的一系列担忧。是的，担忧。你知道，对于你如何具体使用人工智能，你有多大程度的舒适感，你主要用人工智能来写的那种代码，这会如何影响，你知道你的感受？如果你写的大多数代码都是为了工作，并且要运行在世界各地的数百万台设备上，显而易见，这会影响你对这些工具的看法。我尽量不，我尽量不，
I'm an old man, but I try not to be, mostly. Let me put it as well that way. Maybe the listeners will understand. In other words, I try not to make arguments of the form, you know, the youth of today, or people don't understand what it was like or whatever. But from what you were saying, like,
我是一个老头，但我尽量不那样，大多数时候。让我换个方式说得好一点。也许听众能听懂。换句话说，我尽量不说那种“现在的年轻人啊”或者“人们不理解以前是什么样”之类的话。但从你刚才说的来看，像，
I think it made me think, like, there is an observation that maybe people of my generation, perhaps were the last to be comfortable with being bored. Because I'm of the generation where, yeah, on a weekend, your mom would say, go out and play, we back for tea. So we did. You know, we just had to go out and find the kids in the neighborhood and find a way to spend our time between, you know, morning and evening.
我想这让我觉得，有一种观察是，也许我这一代人，可能是最后一批能够坦然面对无聊的人。因为我是这样一代人：是的，在周末，你妈妈会说，出去玩吧，回来喝茶。所以我们就去了。你知道，我们只需要出去找邻里的小孩，想办法打发早晨到傍晚之间的时光。
Yeah. Were you bored, though? you're going out to play, you know? Well, I mean, yeah, there were times when I was bored. You have to figure out what to do on your own, right? And you have to take the consequences of your choices. You know, you decide to reenact the popular music video of the day and jump down from that tree.
是啊。不过，你当时觉得无聊吗？你出去玩的时候，你知道的？嗯，我的意思是，是的，有时我确实会觉得无聊。你必须自己想该做什么，对吧？而且你必须承担你选择的后果。你知道，你决定重现当天的流行音乐录影带，然后从那棵树上跳下来。
You need to be okay with the fact that you skinned your knee or whatever. That would be, the music video I'm thinking of would be Stand and Deliver by Adam and the Ants for, anyone who's listening of the same era. I'm sure there's a few people out there. Anyways, where does this leave us? I don't know. I would make one more comment,
你需要接受这样一个事实，即你的膝盖擦破了诸如此类的。那个，我脑子里想的音乐录影带是亚当和蚂蚁乐队（Adam and the Ants）的《Stand and Deliver》，给所有处於同一时代的听众。我确信会有一些这样的人。无论如何，这把我们带到了哪里？我不知道。我会再做一点评论，
which is to say, you know, regarding technology and AI and everything about the modern world, you know, the sentiment I hear often expressed is one of resignation and fatalism of like, well, you know, if we, we don't do this. Someone else just will. The cat's out of the bag. You know, this is the way the world's going. It's not up to me. But I would say, it is up to you to live an authentic life. It is up to you to behave in the way that's consistent with your own morals and ethics.
那就是，你知道，关于技术、人工智能以及现代世界的一切，你知道，我经常听到的情绪是一种辞职和宿命论，仿佛，“好吧，你知道，如果我们不做这个。别人也会做的。覆水难收。你知道，世界就是这样发展的。这不由我决定。”但我要说的是，过一种真实的生活是由你决定的。以符合你自身道德和伦理的方式行事是由你决定的。
You have agency. Let me just leave you with that, Connor. All right. I definitely will, we're going to leave it there because I don't have anything as prophetic sounding or prophetic itself to say. But yeah, it's a hot topic and it's going to be, I mean, it's a very, well, is it exciting? I don't know. That's the thing. It depends on who you talk to. I guess, yeah, we didn't talk about NDC Toronto at all, but that was one of the themes.
你有自主权。康纳，我就把这句话留给你吧。好的。我绝对会的，我们要在这里结束，因为我没有什么听起来像先知那样的话，或者本身就是先知的话要说。但是，是的，这是一个热门话题，而且将会是，我的意思是，这是一个非常，嗯，这令人兴奋吗？我不知道。就是这样。这取决于你和谁交流。我想，是的，我们根本没谈过多伦多 NDC 大会，但那是主题之一。
There was a lot of talks because it wasn't specifically a C++ conference. There was a lot of talks. And depending on who you were talking to, because Shima was visited a couple times because she was working downtown and the conference was downtown. And she sat in for like a lunch and breakfast and chat with some of the people there. And she said she was very surprised because she spends all her time around me. And I am like hyper excited about all this stuff. And then she went to this conference and she was like, wow, like a lot of people do not share your optimistic outlook and are quite like nervous, concerned. Well, it's very difficult to feel negativity towards something when it's paying your paycheck, I think.
有很多演讲，因为这并非专门的 C++ 会议。有很多演讲。根据你交谈的对象——因为希玛去拜访了几次，她在市中心上班，而会议就在市中心。她去参加了一次午餐和早餐，并与那里的几个人聊了聊。她说她非常惊讶，因为她所有的时间都和我在一起。而我对所有这些事情都超级兴奋。然后她去了这个会议，心想，哇，原来很多人并不分享你这种乐观的前景，而且相当紧张、担忧。嗯，当某种东西在为你发薪水时，要对它产生负面情绪是非常困难的，我想。
I mean, this is the problem with work. It's not a problem. It's a downside. of working at a company that is, what's the word, benefiting from this technology, is that people assume that that is what informs my opinion. And I guess we'll never know, because I'm not working at a different company, but I started using these tools before even InVita was paying for them. And I would like to think that regardless of where I worked,
我的意思是，这就是工作的问题所在。这倒不是个问题。这是在一家受益于这项技术的公司工作的缺点，那就是人们认为那是影响我意见的原因。我想我们永远不会知道了，因为我不在别的公司工作，但在英伟达甚至还没为这些工具买单之前，我就开始使用它们了。我愿意认为，无论我在哪里工作，
I still would have built the sites that I built. But anyways, I mean, maybe the last thing I'll say is we were, talking to someone internally at Nvidia, Bryce and I. And he said he didn't want to come on to talk about it. But on the last episode with Bryce and Marco, we're talking about AI. And I brought up that there's a lot of folks, and I'd seen this YouTube video, a guy who said he kind of felt a lot of hopelessness if his job has turned into just like prompting LLMs to generate code.
我仍然会构建我所构建的网站。不过，无论如何，我的意思是，也许我要说的最后一件事是，我们当时，我和布莱斯（Bryce）正在和英伟达内部的某个人交谈。他说他不想上节目来谈这个。但在上一期有布莱斯和马可（Marco）的节目中，我们在谈论人工智能。我提到有很多人，而且我看过这个 YouTube 视频，有个家伙说他觉得挺无望的，如果他的工作变成仅仅是向大语言模型（LLM）发提示词来生成代码的话。
And I said that like, I'm not saying that makes me not excited, but it does like, that when I hear about people's struggling the word or like trying to try to deal with what does this mean for like you know I went into a job to do one thing and now it's you know arguably totally changed what does that mean for people that is I think is like uh I I don't know you know and then I pose the question you know this is something we should care about and I definitely feel like it's it is a problem and let's be completely brutally honest right when I code, maybe you two, when we code, we get the dopamine hit, right? That at the end of the day is a good reason why we love doing what we do, right?
我说，我并不是说这让我不兴奋，但它的确——当我听到人们挣扎于这个词，或者试图去处理这对我们意味着什么时，你知道的，我从事一份工作是为了做一件事，现在它，可以说是彻底改变了，这对人们意味着什么？这我认为是——呃，我不知道，你知道，然后我提出了一个问题，你知道，这是我们应该关心的事情，而且我绝对觉得这是一个问题。让我们极其残酷地诚实，好吗？当我写代码时，也许你们两个，当我们写代码时，我们会获得多巴胺的快感，对吧？归根结底，这就是为什么我们热爱我们所做的事情的一个很好的原因，对吧？
And, you know, whether you do, when you build things, when you see those tests passing, when you're in that kind of flow, when you're in that loop, you're getting that positive feedback, that dopamine. and several people I've talked to say that, you know, prompting AI does not scratch that itch, does not do that for them. It just doesn't. And so, yeah, what does that mean? And is it like, you know, I talked to one person and they said like, ah, well, it's hard for me to feel sympathetic because we're like in one of the most privileged industries. And there's a lot of people in the world that have way worse jobs and they don't get any dopamine hits. They're just doing something and I was like, well, that's, that is true.
而且，你知道，无论你做什么，当你构建东西时，当你看到那些测试通过时，当你处于那种心流状态时，当你处于那个循环中时，你就会得到那种积极的反馈，那种多巴胺。我交谈过的几个人说，你知道，向人工智能提示并不能解决那种渴望，对他们来说没有这种效果。根本就没有。所以，是的，这意味着什么？这就像是，你知道，我和一个人谈过，他们说，啊，好吧，我很难感到同情，因为我们处于最具有特权的行业之一。世界上有很多人做着糟糕得多的工作，而且他们根本没有任何多巴胺快感。他们只是在做某种事情，而我说，嗯，那是真的。
But that's also like telling someone that their problems don't matter because someone else has like, whatever, a worse problem or a worse situation, which I don't think is, it's not going to make that person feel better. That, like, if your response is like, well, how would you just be grateful, even though you don't like your job anymore, you know? Both things can be true. We can be grateful that we have jobs that we enjoy, but we can also want to preserve those experiences. Yeah. Anyway, so it's, I don't know, I find myself still excited about these tools, but as I see peers in my industry be more like and more concerned or not share the same excitement, I do, I don't know, gives me more pause for concern of like, you know, ultimately at the end of the day, we're trying to, I mean, I don't know if that's actually what society's goal is, but, you know, I would hope that, you know, we're trying to build a world where people can live happily and coexist. and live meaningful lives. And if we're like, if a tool gets invented that is stripping a certain percentage of one's
但这也像是告诉某人他们的问不重要，因为别人有，不管怎样，更严重的问题或更糟糕的处境，我认为这不会让那个人感觉更好。如果你的回应是，好吧，你怎么就不能心怀感激呢，即使你不再喜欢你的工作了，你知道？这两件事可以同时成立。我们既可以感激我们拥有自己喜欢的工作，也可以想要保留那些体验。是的。不管怎样，所以，我不知道，我发现自己仍然对这些工具感到兴奋，但当我看到我行业的同行越来越担心，或者不分享相同的兴奋时，我不知道，这让我更加感到担忧，你知道，归根结底，我们正试图，我的意思是，我不知道这是否真的是社会的最终目标，但是，你知道，我希望，你知道，我们正在努力建立一个让人类能够幸福生活并共存的世界。过上有意义的生活。如果我们——如果发明了一种工具，它剥夺了某一部分人的
meaning from their life due to the fact that they had a job that they loved and now they, like, I was like, that doesn't sound great. Anyway, so will any of this make it in or will I just cut it right at your prophetic statement as a better ending? Well, it's up to you. It's up to you. But we've certainly had an interesting discussion. This has been, you know, like I said, this,
他们生活中的意义，因为他们曾经有一份热爱的工作，而现在他们——就像我说的，这听起来不太好。无论如何，所以这些内容会有哪一部分被保留，还是我会直接在你那句充满先知色彩的陈述处戛然而止，作为更好的结尾？好吧，由你决定。由你决定。但我们确实进行了一次有趣的讨论。这一直是，你知道，就像我说的，这个，
you should measure the amount of dead air we have in this podcast and it might be among the you haven't made measurements over time but well it's funny yeah we have to stop talking at some point but I find Shima and I all of our conversations these days are you know what is the best way to live life and you know what should what should we really be optimizing for and and with respect to careers and whatnot right and going into like parenting and balancing work life balance and all this stuff and and then you talk to some people and they're like, I would never want to have kids right now. It's the worst time to bring
你应该衡量一下我们这个播客中有多少沉默时间，它可能在其中——虽然你没有随着时间推移去衡量过，但好吧，这很有趣，是的，我们在某个时刻必须停止说话，但我发现希玛和我，我们如今所有的对话都是，你知道，生活的最佳方式是什么，你知道，我们真正应该优化的目标是什么，关于职业生涯等等，对吧？然后进入到育儿、平衡工作与生活平衡以及所有这些事情，然后你和一些人交谈，他们会说，我绝不想现在要孩子。现在是把孩子带到这个世界上最糟糕的时机。
children in the world. And I'm just like, what? I mean, everyone's entitled to their opinion, but I would just say, we haven't had the kid yet. So maybe this is the best time to ask me. But it has been like the most magical experience seeing my wife like grow our future kid. And I remember listening. I won't name the name because a lot of people, uh, have to take issue with him. But he has like a whole subsection of a podcast interview one time where he just gushes about having kids and how he thinks it's a shame that like, because there's a, I think globally, I'm not sure if there's any, I think there's some countries in Africa that are having upticks. In the West, we might say, the trend is down, I think.
而我只想说，什么？我的意思是，每个人都有权发表自己的意见，但我只想说，我们还没生孩子呢。所以也许现在是向我询问的最佳时机。但看着我妻子孕育我们未来的孩子，这确实是犹如魔法般的体验。我记得听过。我不会说出名字，因为很多人，呃，对他的观点有异议。但他曾经在一次播客采访中有一个整整的小节，他在那里滔滔不绝地讲述养育孩子的话题，以及他认为这是一件多么遗憾的事，因为——我认为在全球范围内，我不确定是不是，我认为非洲有些国家的出生率在上升。而在西方，我们可能会说，趋势在下降，我想。
Yeah, less and less people are having kids. And everybody can have, you know, live your own life. But I just, I just think it's like the, going to be the biggest adventure. And anyways, a lot of conversations, yeah, these days. It definitely seems like, I'm not sure. When the internet was coming out, was there this much, like, buzz around? because I was being born at that time and I guess maybe you were too young
是的，越来越多的人不想要孩子了。每个人都可以拥有，你知道，过你自己的生活。但我只是，我只是认为这将会是最大的冒险。无论如何，是的，这些天有很多对话。这绝对看起来像，我不确定。当互联网刚问世时，是否有这么多的，比如，热议？因为我当时刚出生，我想也许你太年轻了
I don't know if like... When are you talking about? Like, early 90s? Yeah, okay, so I was first on the internet in 1992. Okay, yeah, was there the same amount of like how is this going to affect society and whatnot or, like, concern? I don't think so.
我不知道是否……你是在说什么时候？比如90年代初？是的，好吧，我是在1992年首次上网的。好的，是的，当时是否有同样多的关于这会对社会产生什么影响之类的话题，或者说担忧？我不这么认为。
Not that I remember. It's funny, I remember, I remember when spam was invented. Does that seem crazy? Does that, I remember. I remember Cantor and Siegel, a law firm, posted the first, what is recognized generally as the first spam message to a Usenet news group. And the reaction from the community was, as you would predict, they were kind of outraged.
据我所记得的没有。有趣的是，我记得，我记得垃圾邮件是什么时候被发明的。这听起来是不是很疯狂？是不是，我记得。我记得坎托和西格尔（Cantor and Siegel）律师事务所发布了第一条被普遍认为发送到 Usenet 新闻组的第一条垃圾邮件。社区的反应正如你所预料的那样，他们有点愤怒。
But Cantor and Siegel were completely unapologetic. They basically said, we can do this. And that was the birth of spam. A sad day. Yeah. Is that the ending? Is that the ending? Oh my gosh.
但坎托和西格尔完全没有道歉。他们基本上说，我们可以这么做。这就是垃圾邮件的诞生。悲伤的一天。是的。这是结尾吗？这是结尾吗？哦，天哪。
A sad day. Yeah, I don't know. I guess, I guess, yeah. Like I always say, though, these are, the conversations that we end up having on these podcasts are exactly what we, if we, if I was at C++ now and we were chatting, I'm sure we'd be talking about a bunch of the talks that we saw. But, yeah, over dinner and stuff, these are the kinds of conversations that we probably would be having.
悲伤的一天。是的，我不知道。我想，我想，是的。正如我常说的，这些，我们最终在这些播客中进行的对话正是我们——如果我在 C++ 大会上，我们正在聊天，我确信我们会谈论我们看到的许多演讲。但是，是的，在晚餐和其他场合，这些可能是我们会进行的对话。
Yeah. So, people should. should go to their local beatup and go to conferences if they can. Oh, yeah, yeah. Yeah, everybody should go. If there's one positive thing to come out of all this, is it positive? Who knows? Is that I think that like the in person, especially in a world now for remote work, like that stuff is, it's become like more and more important.
是的。所以，人们应该。如果可以的话，应该去他们当地的聚会并去参加会议。哦，是的，是的。是的，每个人都应该去。如果这一切能产生什么积极的事情的话，它是积极的吗？谁知道呢？那就是我认为，面对面，特别是在如今远程工作的世界里——这东西，它变得越来越重要。
It's always been the most important thing and it's now even more important. Yeah. And that's the thing. Yeah, it's even more important now. The number one thing you can do for your career is go to the meeting. meetups, go to the conferences, do the networking. It may be hard. It's certainly hard for, you know, your stereotypical standard nerds to do that, which I count myself among.
它一直是最重要的事，现在甚至更重要了。是的。就是这样。是的，现在甚至更重要了。你能为你的职业生涯做的第一件事就是去参加聚会，去参加会议，去进行社交。这可能很难。对于你的那些标准书呆子类型的内向者来说，这肯定很难做到，我自己也算其中之一。
But yeah, it really is more important now than ever with the, especially with the, with the job market the way it is, you know, where it's basically devolved into AI sending resumes to other. their AIs, as far as I can tell. The thing you have to do is actually get in touch with a human and network and get an in. Yeah, yeah. And that's the thing is people hear the word, that's the thing. Yeah. Here's a little advice too from someone, you know, I wish someone had told me this when I was younger in my career.
但真的，现在比以往任何时候都更加重要，尤其是面对这种就业市场，就我所能看出的而言，它基本上退化成了人工智能向其他人工智能发送简历。你必须做的事是真正与人类接触、建立社交并找到敲门砖。是的，是的。这就是问题所在，人们听到这个词——就是这样。这里也有一点来自某人的建议，你知道，我希望在我职业生涯更年轻的时候有人能告诉我这些。
People hear the word networking and they hear the word mentoring and they think of this like, oh, I got to go, I got to go to this event and I got to network. No, showing up at the event is like the net. You're naturally going to start chatting with someone, and you don't have to be thinking, oh, I've got to ask for someone's business card. Like, just showing up at the conference or at the event is the networking itself. And mentoring, like, I actually got this from, say what you will about the book in general, but Cheryl Samberg wrote a book called Lean In. In that book, she talks about how one time someone asked if she could be her mentor. And she had been having these little five or 15 minute conversations with that person over the last couple years.
人们听到“社交”这个词，听到“指导”这个词，就会想到诸如“哦，我得去，我得去参加这个活动，我得去社交”。不，出现在活动现场本身就是社交。你自然而然地会开始和某人聊天，你不必去想“哦，我得向某人要名片”。只需出现在会议或活动现场，这本身就是社交。至于指导——其实我是从这本，无论你怎么评价这本书本身，但雪莉·桑德伯格（Sheryl Sandberg）写过一本名为《向前一步》（Lean In）的书。在这本书中，她谈到曾几何时，有人问她是否可以成为对方的导师。在过去几年里，她一直和那个人进行着这种五分钟或十五分钟的小对话。
And she was thinking herself like, she's like, you already are. what do you think we've been doing this whole time exactly it is the five minute conversations or whatever you bumping into someone people don't realize like your peers can be mentors you know you're you're the folks on your team yeah yeah you can have different mentors for different areas of your life right exactly yeah and i and i realize too at one point in my life i you know people don't know this but i actually emailed sean parent i was like hey can you be my mentor and then he probably i don't think he ever replied to the email but like in hindsight having then read the book later,
她当时心里在想，心想：“你已经是了。你以为我们这一直在做什么呢？”完全就是这样，五分钟的对话或者任何偶遇。人们没有意识到，你的同龄人可以成为导师，你知道，你团队里的伙伴们。是的，你可以为生活中的不同领域拥有不同的导师，对吧？完全正确，是的。而且我也曾一度意识到，在我的生活中的某个时刻，你知道，人们对此并不了解，但我实际上给肖恩·帕朗（Sean Parent）发过电子邮件，我说，嘿，你能做我的导师吗？然后他可能——我不认为他回复过那封邮件，但事后回想起来，后来读了那本书之后，
I realized, wait, like, Sean Parent, like, I'm very lucky to call him a friend now, but he was like a mentor, like, even, even just watching his videos before having ever met him. That is like, you know, you can be mentored by someone that you've never actually spoken to just by consuming their content and reading their blogs and stuff. And friends can be mentors, sure, as well.
我意识到，等等——肖恩·帕朗，我现在很幸运能称他为朋友，但他就像一位导师，甚至，仅仅是通过在从未见过他之前观看他的视频。这就是，你知道的，你可以通过消费某人的内容和阅读他们的博客等，来接受一个你从未真正交过谈的人的指导。朋友也可以是导师，当然也是如此。
Yeah. I've, you know, the people who you enjoy, the people whose company you enjoy, the people you enjoy at work, the people whose friendship you enjoy, keep those relationships going. Yeah. Like, it's worth it.
是的。我，你知道的，那些你喜欢的人，那些你喜欢和他们在一起的人，那些你在工作中喜欢的人，那些你喜欢他们的友谊的人，保持这些关系。是的。这很值得。
Yeah. I mean, that's what, I mean, this conversation has gone all over the place. But like, sometimes she and I, we joke about like, oh, you know, what if AI really becomes super, and, you know, this place is everybody. And it's like, well, we're all going to have to find purpose.
是的。我的意思是，这就是——我的意思是，这次对话已经天南海北地聊了很多。但是，有时希玛和我，我们会开玩笑说，哦，你知道，如果人工智能真的变得超级强大，取代了所有人，会怎么样？这就像是，好吧，我们都得找到生活的意义。
And, you know, I'm just going to start running a whole, I'm going to be in the best shape of my life ever, because my, my, you know, hour, hour and a half runs. And they're going to turn into two or three hours. runs a day and, you know, board games. And there are other things that people do, you know, gardening. And, you know, we have a little whatever backyard now. And, you know, I don't garden, but, you know, I've gotten really into mowing the lawns.
而且，你知道的，我打算开始进行全面的——我要保持我一生中最好的身体状态，因为我的，我的，你知道的，一小时、一个半小时的跑步。它们将变成每天两到三小时的跑步，还有，你知道的，桌游。还有人们会做的其他事情，比如园艺。而且，你知道的，我们现在后院有一个小小的什么地方。而且，我不搞园艺，但是，你知道的，我非常迷恋修剪草坪。
There are things you can, you know, get meaning and, like, enjoyment from other than work. And, like, I don't actually think that's the way society is going. But sometimes we joke is like, oh, well, you know, what actually are we going to do? And, like, if that is the case, people, there will have to be some shift in, like, and probably the most meaningful thing you can do. is maintain your friendships and relationships with the folks that you enjoy meeting up with. Because... Oh, and I have one piece of advice for being a dad, at least in the early days.
除了工作之外，你还可以从其他事物中获得意义和乐趣。而且，我其实不认为世界会那样发展。但有时我们会开玩笑说，哦，好吧，你知道，我们到底要做什么？而且，如果是那样的话，人们，观念必须有所转变，并且可能你能做的最有意义的事情，就是维持你与那些你喜欢相聚的人的友谊和关系。因为……哦，我还有一个关于如何当爸爸的建议，至少在最初的那几天里。
Figure out which shirts you like and set them aside. Because your job as dad is mostly to get spit up on the shoulder, right? That's going to happen to many of your shirts. Luckily, almost all my favorite shirts, except for two, are shirts that I got, quote unquote, for free. from including the one I'm wearing right now. Okay, okay. From races. And I have like three times as many as I would need.
弄清楚你喜欢哪些衬衫并把它们挑出来。因为你当爸爸的工作主要就是在肩膀上吐奶，对吧？你的许多衬衫都会遭遇这种待遇。幸运的是，我几乎所有最喜欢的衬衫，除了两件之外，都是我“免费”获得的衬衫，包括我身上现在穿的这件。好吧，好吧。从跑步比赛中拿到的。我的数量大概是我实际需要的三倍。
Oh, you're in good stead then. Like, yeah, conference shirts, race shirts, whatever. All those free t-shirts, put them to good use. Yes. And, you know, even though I've donated a ton of them over the years, I still have probably, because I kind of... You probably still have a few dozen. Oh, yeah, yeah.
哦，那你就稳了。就像，是的，会议T恤，比赛T恤，不管什么。所有这些免费的T恤，物尽其用。是的。而且，你知道，尽管这些年来我捐出了大量这类衣服，我大概还是有，因为我有点……你可能还有几十件。哦，对，对。
And there's the ones that you don't actually fit great, but you're just like, ah, you know, I might need this at some point. They're about to come. Yeah, you can throw it on at 2 a.m. for the feeding. Yeah. Or they're just going to become my daily drivers, you know, if I'm getting sick on every day, it's going to be like, you know what? You're right.
还有那些其实不太合身，但你只会觉得，啊，你知道的，我有时可能会用得上。它们就要派上用场了。是的，你可以在凌晨两点喂奶时随便套上一件。是的。或者它们只是会变成我的日常穿着，你知道的，如果我每天都吐得像生病一样，那就会变成，你知道吗？你说得对。
I'm going to set my favorite race t-shirts aside, and we're going to put these ones that I don't particularly love in rotation for the next few months. Yeah, that is good advice. And luckily, I have a whole rotation of free t-shirts ready to go. All right, we should probably call it here. Be sure to check these show notes, either in your podcast app or at ADSP, thepodcast.com for links to anything we mentioned in today's episode, as well as a link to a
我要把最喜欢的比赛T恤放在一边，然后在接下来的几个月里轮流穿那些我并不是特别喜欢的衣服。是的，那是个好建议。幸运的是，我有一整套随时可以上场的免费T恤。好了，我们差不多该到此结束了。请务必查看这些节目笔记，无论是在你的播客应用中还是在 ADSP, thepodcast.com 上，都可以找到今天节目中提到的任何内容的链接，以及一个可以让你留下想法、评论和问题的
get-up discussion where you can leave thoughts, comments, and questions. Thanks for listening. We hope you enjoyed and have a great day. I am the anti-brace. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
讨论区的链接。感谢收听。希望你们喜欢，祝你们有美好的一天。我是反布莱斯。本期节目还没有评论。点击转录文本中的任何句子即可发表评论。